Mr.
Leonard Ferati
Thank you,
Madam President,
Members of Parliament.
I would first like to respond to Mrs.
Conti who attributes animal characteristics to foreigners by saying that
you can't make a donkey that isn't thirsty drink.
These words are better totally inappropriate and at worst totally scandalous.
The SVP spends its time doing moral lessons the SVP spends its time
doing moral lessons and I would like to remind them that these types
of words have no place in this honorable assembly.
Thank you I am not finished Please a little silence.
I told you if you have a reaction don't hesitate press the button
I will give you the floor the mom came What is beautiful?
Our democracy It is alive and jealous on both sides of the globe.
But let me tell you,
ladies and gentlemen,
that our democracy is imperfect,
partial and partial.
Our political system Clive the Genevans between those
who vote and those who do not vote,
it politically discriminates against those who are already discriminated
against in employment and housing,
and in administrative matters it discriminates against
people who participate in the social,
economic and fiscal life of the canton.
It is important to ask the ethical question of the legitimacy of democracy.
How can we imagine that this honorable assembly governs this Canton by using tax
revenues subsidized in part by foreigners and discriminates against them when it
is necessary to participate politically in decisions that affect them.
Are we mature enough to dissociate nationality from citizenship?
The electoral participation of foreigners would
not make our democracy less beautiful,
it would be more legitimate and more accomplished.
It would be greater and will show how avant-garde
our canton is in terms of democracy.
Thank you .
π‘πΌπ‘πΌ